The finale of "House of the Dragon"
masterfully echoed the show's earliest
episodes, while also improving one of the most
impressive sets in "Game of Thrones" history.
Throughout Season 1, the Painted Table of
Dragonstone has made brief but uneventful
appearances. This is the very same table
around which Stannis Baratheon and later
Daenerys Targaryen draw up their
battle plans in "Game of Thrones."
"Conquering Westeros would be easy for you.
But you're not here to be Queen of the Ashes."
Rhaenyra expresses a similar wish in the
finale while standing around the same table.
"I do not wish to rule over
a kingdom of ash and bone."
We know from the books that the table — which
doubles as a map of Westeros — was commissioned
by none other than King Aegon I himself before
his conquest, which is why it's in Dragonstone
instead of King's Landing. Many fans considered
it one of the coolest pieces of set design in
the screen adaptations of Martin's world — and
that's before we knew it could be illuminated.
Apparently, the instruction manual
got lost sometime in between the
Dance of the Dragons and Robert's Rebellion,
as no one in "Game of Thrones" seemed to know
about the table's awesome light-up feature.
If you experienced déjà vu when Otto
arrived with his envoy at Dragonstone,
that was intentional. The Hand of King Aegon
II arrives unannounced to offer Rhaenyra terms.
Daemon is there waiting with guards who are
loyal to the Blacks, but Otto says he's under
strict instructions to only deliver Queen
Alicent's message to "Princess" Rhaenyra.
The Black Queen flies in on the back
of Syrax and lands on the bridge behind
the Green party. She dismounts, then
positions herself in between Daemon and
Otto. The two men are hoping
for war, Daemon outwardly so.
Otto is clearly hoping for an escalation on
the Rogue Prince's part so he has justification
to kill them all and stymy any challenge to
his grandson. It's left to Rhaenyra, again,
to force cooler heads to prevail. She's
angry enough that her birthright has been
stolen to toss Otto's pin into the water
below, but after he shows her Alicent's
"message," she's steady enough to tell him
she'll give her an answer the following day.
"King's Landing will have
my answer on the morrow."
This scene is a callback to "House of the Dragon"
Episode 2, in which Otto sails to Dragonstone to
confront Daemon about his seizure of what's
supposed to be the heir's seat. Back then,
a teenage Rhaenyra landed Syrax in almost
exactly the same spot and walked to almost
exactly the same place between who was then just
her uncle and her father's "vulture" of a Hand.
But during that debacle, her back was turned to
Otto while she dealt with Daemon. In Episode 10,
her back is to her husband as she tries to
outwit the engineer of the coup against her.
Alicent Hightower doesn't show up in Episode
10, but it's clear she thinks she has an ace
up her sleeve. Before Rhaenyra gives Otto her
non-answer, he hands her a folded-up piece of
paper and lets her know that the Queen has not
forgotten the love they once had for each other.
As her envoy, Otto insists that Alicent wants
to avoid bloodshed and broker peace. Rhaenyra
opens up what viewers might have expected to
be a hand-written message. Instead, we see
an illustrated page from a history textbook.
This is the page that a very young Rhaenyra
tore out of the book when she was supposed to
be studying with Alicent at the Septa's behest.
Alicent's token of affection is also shrewd
statecraft. That she kept the page is meant to
show her friend-turned-enemy that she has been
pining for what they once had all these years,
but she's also hoping the ploy
works in the Greens' favor.
It's significant that the entry is about
Nymeria, a woman who ruled alongside her
husband and who brought her people together.
It's also symbolic that, in their youth,
a willful Rhaenyra ripped out the page
and gave it to an obedient Alicent, while,
as mothers, a bolder Alicent returns the page to
a Rhaenyra who's worried about duty and honor.
In discussing their path forward, Queen
Rhaenyra tells the Black Council that she
wants to know who her allies are before
she sends people to war in her name.
Her loyalists assure her some houses, like
Celtigar, can be depended upon for support,
but the fealty of houses who swore oaths
long ago will have to be reaffirmed.
Chief among these are Houses Tully, Arryn, Stark,
and Baratheon. We know how that last one
panned out, but the Blacks' efforts to
secure alliances with the other three will
likely be the order of business in Season 2.
That means we'll probably be meeting the
ancestors of the Tullys, Starks, and Arryns
and visiting these iconic "Game of Thrones"
locations. Technically, it'll be the show's
second visit to the Vale, as we did get a brief
stopover there when Daemon knocked off Rhea Royce.
We can't say if the dragon fight happens in
the show as it does in "Fire & Blood." It's
a stormy night in both versions, which makes it
hard for onlookers to see in written accounts.
What everyone agrees upon is that Aemond didn't
fly to Storm's End with the intent to kill Luke,
and that all anyone saw was two dragons
tangling in a fury of fire and lightning.
"House of the Dragon" renders Aemond's
kin-slaying of Luke as something closer
to manslaughter than murder. When they
jump on the backs of their dragons,
Luke and Aemond both speak to
their mounts in High Valyrian.
Though the one-eyed Prince's evil
laughter and his insistence that
Luke owes him a debt suggest otherwise, once
Arrax sprays Vhagar in the face with flames,
Aemond tries to put on the brakes. He screams
"Dohaeris!" at Vhagar, who chomps down on
poor Luke and Arrax anyway. The word "Dohaeris"
might sound familiar to "Game of Thrones" fans.
"Valar morghulis."
"Valar dohaeris."
"Valar Dohaeris" is a common phrase used
in Essos which translates to "all men must
serve," often said in conjunction with
"valar morghulis", which means "all men
must die." It's also the title of the first
episode of Season 3 of "Game of Thrones."
For the purposes of "House of the
Dragon," that two royal boys can't
get their dragons to "dohaeris"
indicates Viserys was right.
"They're a power men never
should have trifled with."